muy buenas tardes
la audiencia comenzó ya hace algunos
instantes con el resto de testimonios de
los sobrevivientes y de familiares de
las víctimas de lo ocurrido esa noche
del 13 de noviembre de 2015 aquí en
parís en especial lo sucedido en el
estadio de francia porque allí se
produjeron tres explosiones tres
kamikaze se hicieron explotar esa noche
pero hay estos hechos son bastante
desconocidos en realidad de la gente la
gente no sabe incluso que hubo una
víctima mortal que se llamaba manuel
díaz de hecho su hija dio su testimonio
el día de ayer desde ayer pues hemos
escuchado testimonios bastante fuertes
muy impactantes la mayoría de ellos
incluso ya en la tarde de hoy pues se
tienen dificultad a contar lo sucedido
sin llorar sin explotar en el llanto
ante estos recuerdos y también hay algo
que digamos que se ha visto y que se ha
escuchado en todos los testimonios y es
la dificultad de cada una de estas
personas en hacer valer su estatus como
víctimas de terrorismo justamente cuando
han tenido que repetir sendas veces lo
sucedido ante las autoridades
administrativas francesas en aras de
seguir esa compensación financiera del
fondo de garantía para las víctimas de
terrorismo en la en el día de hoy se
esperaba unas 15 personas que dieran su
testimonio por el presidente de en la
corte son luís dijo hoy que hay varias
de ellas que dijeron que no se van a
presentar tienen miedo de que se den a
conocer sus identidades al público esto
a pesar de que él desde ayer y hoy
volvió a hacer hincapié en esto y es que
son audiencias que no son públicas y se
le ha pedido expresamente y de manera
muy repetida a los medios de
comunicación que eviten dar pues dar a
conocer la identidad de estas personas y
que por favor guarden el anonimato así
que por ahora pues se continuaremos
trayéndoles lo que continúan diciendo
estas personas de los testimonios espero
sobre todo que esta tarde ya después de
las personas que estuvieron en el
estadio de francia comiencen los
testimonios de las personas que estaban
en el carrillo uno de los restaurantes
que fue atacado ya en el centro de parís